I was on the Secret Service's
most-wanted list by the way at this
point mm-hmm what year is this oh six or
so well this is oh oh four no no this is
this is oh five I wanna say this in the
thick of the mortgage industry oh four
oh five right I had gone to Las Vegas
with Becky KY we at this point I'm
surveying homeless people to get their
information I've come up with a survey
form that says we're surveying homeless
people to get to determine where we're
going to place our next homeless
facility I work for the Salvation Army
I've got a little badge I know it's
horrible I feel bad so not judging me so
they have no they have no idea they're
good for 20 bucks they're filling out
the form i order all your all your stuff
I got your high school transcripts I got
everything I then go in the DMV I get a
driver's license I'm driving I buy a car
in your name I don't even need that you
know I well of course I go to Social
Security I get a Social Security issued
so I've got clean Social Security I got
credit I got a house I got whatever I
want in your name you're some guy that
lives under a bridge in Las Vegas now
I'm in South Carolina I remember the guy
this is funny because I would be the guy
and said the guy had gotten in Las Vegas
I meet him while I'm doing the survey I
asked about does he have any a criminal
record
he says he's got several arrests for
prostitution but they were misdemeanors
I said okay he's a me I realize I go so
you're a male prostitute he's like yeah
I was like okay whatever so I take the
thing I go to South Carolina
I go to DMV I get a driver's license in
his name I then go buy two houses I did
after I buy those houses I satisfied a
loan in his name satisfy the loan in
both those houses I then go to multiple
mortgage companies and I borrow money on
the houses one of them I borrow like
three four hundred thousand the next one
I borrow like close to a million dollars
on the house their house is only worth
two hundred thousand my go in the bank
I'm cashing checks I'm pulling out four
or five six hundred thousand dollars
over the course of a few weeks Becky by
the way the whole time every time I
would go into a bank this didn't not all
the time but a lot of times she would
say
what happens if you get arrested and I
would say if I get arrested they'll be
arresting me as the guys name was Gary
Sullivan
they'll be arresting me as Gary Sullivan
the male prostitute the male prostitute
they will not run my prints right away
because my identity is not in question
back then they didn't have the scanners
so they're not gonna run they'll go
Scania but it doesn't necessarily run it
through AFIS so that's a new thing
they're doing the scanners now right
well they didn't at the time they had
them but yours it wasn't they weren't I
said look the worst that'll happen I get
arrested it'll be a minor charge get me
a lawyer get me out on bail we'll take
off she goes okay so I go in the bank
one day I go into a Wachovia I'm waiting
to get cash a check for like six grand
and I cashed pulled out 50,000 60,000
under that account I had like eight
accounts well next thing I know BAM a
cop walks up where they grabbed me from
behind they arrest me they walk me in
the back I'm done that's it I already
know I'm on so Secret Service is most
wanted list this is it they take me back
they sit me down all the customers are
looking at me guy says mr. Sullivan
we're waiting for the detective to show
up I'm thinking detective okay that's
like FBI or something I guess he's
coming well then this cop comes in and
he says hey I'm with the Richmond County
Sheriff's Department we understand you
know we walk ovios fraud department
called us they said you're running some
kind of a scam you're pulling out cash I
go are you serious he goes you know I
said look man am i under arrest he's
like no I said why I feel like I'm under
arrest and I show him like my cops to go
take those off in takes them off me they
call the Wachovia head of security he's
on the phone he says okay now what's
going on he's borrowed how many loans
because he said you got three loans on
the house I actually had like six they
only caught three and I said okay I said
yeah is that illegal and the guy goes do
you know I'm not really sure I remember
right then thinking I'm walking out of
here I got just got to convince this guy
haven't done anything wrong while Kobe
is telling him I've done something wrong
but if I can get out of here so I start
arguing with him this guy saying he's
got all first mortgages I'm saying
they're not all first mortgages while
Kobe is first mortgage so they know they
lent me a first mortgage
I said and he goes who are the other
ones ending I go and he goes oh SunTrust
and so it's over right SunTrust is a
credit line the other one is a second
mortgage that's the three and he's like
well why did you but he wants to know
why you brought him took out all that
money half a million dollars on two
hundred thousand dollar house I said bro
I don't know how it works I work for a
labor company I give my business card I
said all I know is I came here the woman
I told her I needed half a million
dollars the loan officer said I can get
you this much I got a friend over here
she can get you this much this much I
sounds to me like I got a problem at the
bank I don't know anything about it he
says okay okay and the guys screaming
it's a shotgunning scam he's you don't
understand he's doing this he's doing
that he's like and I'm certain I
wouldn't know how to do this I don't
know what he's talking about and he says
yeah I don't this guy is he works for a
labor company he doesn't and he's like
why are you pulling out all this cash
like oh I'm cashing guys checks I mean I
got a bunch of Mexican guys that doing
roofs and they don't take checks or I
give him a check and I cashed a check I
mean is that illegal now that's not a
look ok so then he says uh his ID his ID
starts with zero zero zero and he goes
no it's a real idea what's a real ID
it's a real IDR this guy was in
California
Wachovia hmm he was no our ID start with
zero zero zero and he said he said trust
me I've run him through NCIC it's him
this is Gary Sullivan and I go oh now
I'm not Gary Sullivan oh come on bro
what are we doing here man what are we
doing
he goes I know I know he's okay he and
he says okay so he talks to the guy they
this guy literally is arguing with him
he eventually says okay I'm gonna take
him downtown have him fill out a police
report I'm waiting for the district
attorney to call me back I don't even
know what to charge them with if I can
charge him with anything I think you
need to talk to your loan officer hangs
up the phone I then get up when I get up
the two sheriff's deputies are there and
he says do you have a driver's license
and I said this is an ID and I said yeah
I have a driver's license I said but
it's in Nevada I don't know if Gary
Sullivan it he's a homeless guy he's
blowing guys for 20 bucks a pop on the
park bench I don't know if he's got a
night driver's license where the cop
says I'll check he goes out to his car
he comes back and he goes he does have a
driver's license and he goes okay it's
cool and he goes yeah here's well it
says he's five foot ten and they look at
me and I go with the good pair of shoes
and they all go ha ha ha and so at the
same time he says
I remember he had said something about
that's right you're from Nevada and all
the cops look at me and they look at
each other and they kind of grin and I
realize he said he ran me through NCIC
he thinks I've been arrested in Nevada
for prostitution and I thought oh how it
was just ridiculous so they gave me my
ID I follow him to the police station
when I we were gonna go to say I
literally almost want to say listen man
it's all [ __ ] on my name's Matt Cox
um they followed me to the police
station I go in the police station fill
out the police report I'm waiting in the
hallway my wanted posted by the way is
on the wall there's all these posters my
only color one on the whole wall you're
seeing it I'm seeing it I'm pissing in
my pants when I leave Oh before I got
there when I was I fall took my own car
when I'm driving there Becky calls me I
pick up the phone and she goes oh my god
what's going on and I say I tell her
what happened and she goes you don't
understand
they just raised you to number one and
the Secret Service's most-wanted list
you've got to get out of there I said I
can't there's a sheriff's deputy behind
me that the other guys in front of me I
got to play this out and I say the worst
that happened is I get arrested you get
me out on bond shoes I'm not getting you
out on bond I'm not getting you a lawyer
she had like six hundred thousand in
cash of your month my money she was now
living in Houston and I'm like are you
still together or no well we're not
together we're we're still changing
we're not good bad others yeah okay she
we hate each other
so I go into the police station fill out
the report guy walks me out I get my car
I leave I go straight to two more banks
and get out more money until another
person recognize him he goes to make a
phone call I jump in my car and I leave
you
[Music]